thank you
come over here with me man okay I called
as soon as this happens
I understand
okay so here's I'm gonna have you do if
you can uh maybe help tyros and CPR on
that one right now you tell me I'm right
here okay just hang tight right here if
anybody gotten all your information
do you have a driver's license
okay I'm just gonna write it down here
okay just let you know I got body
cameras okay
middle initial I don't have one okay
last name
phone number
okay
um
were you leaving the bar were you coming
this down the road I mean I was coming
okay just gotten my night started were
you going this direction or this
direction I was coming this direction
okay here's what I'm gonna have you do
um let's just get let's get away from
the scene a little bit let them do
they're saying okay this is your car
right the correct the red car you were
the only one in the vehicle okay come
over here to my spot car okay yep
can you take your purse off and just set
that on here we gotta
yeah do you have anything illegal on you
in your purse okay have you had any
marijuana tonight no okay do you set
those on the car for me for them yep yep
set that down there on your phone yes
ma'am all right just come over here put
your hands on my car he's got a pass
search before I put you in my car okay
okay no pockets or anything
okay
until we figure out how we're gonna
handle this I'm gonna have you sit
uncuffed in the back seat of my car I'm
gonna get you out we're gonna probably
do some filter body test and all that I
got some more questions for you but
right now I'm gonna have you sit down
just so we're out of the roadway okay
right over here
thank you
scoot that over for me okay you want to
do it here we go are you hurt at all or
need or need Medics yourself
because your entire I mean your car's
pretty beat us I'm making sure are you
bleeding anywhere
that little blood sweater on your hands
maybe from your glass see you got glass
cut all over you I think I'm okay okay
all right hang tight a minute
okay suspect that's her
um they're probably gonna call both of
them
but yeah go check out her car sorry all
right all right so here's the deal just
because I do have you in the back of a
police car I don't have you in custody
or under arrest but obviously you don't
feel like you're free to go right now
right so I'm just going to read your
Miranda Rights you understand what they
are and we're going to talk about what
happened on the accident okay
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can be used against you
in court you have a right to talk to
lawyer before question and have a
present with you while you're being
questioned cannot afford a higher lawyer
want to be provided for you because
before question okay you understanding
of your rights how do you say your first
name Stephanie okay that being said will
you talk to me whatever happened okay
all right so explain detail just what
happened prior to the accident I was
throttle and I was almost here as you
can see were you were you driving this
way or that coming down that side right
here this way okay and suddenly one
person walked out in front of me okay
and my car got hit I called you as soon
as they okay you called 9-1-1 I called
9-1-1
and then someone 's oh someone else is
good I'm just like oh my God how did
that happen okay what happened when you
hit the one person what happened I just
called you that's all I know did they
fall down right away or did you get out
and help them or what happened I got out
I called you and then everyone else came
out so I like kind of just let them okay
come and take over the situation okay
um but I promise you like I only know
one person got hit and I'm just like
they came out of nowhere because I
safe driver I get it hang on one minute
just because it started to rain here
all right
um if you had to ask me how fast were
you going when you hit the person
I would say I was doing at least at
least 40 at least 40. maybe 40 to 45 but
at least 40. okay all right
um do you think you were going too fast
for this area at the time with the
darkness I honestly don't think I was
going too fast because I tried to be
precautionary about where I'm at
um but I just know that someone one
person came out of nowhere did you have
your headlights on yes sir bright zone
or just regular headlights regular okay
okay so obviously you saw them it was no
time to react we're trying to stop
the word okay all right where were you
coming from tonight I was coming from
Tavern uh 41 on Sterling Avenue Tavern
31 on 31 Tavern 41 on Sterling Peoria
okay and you left the tavern 41 and
drove straight here yes sir okay over
the course of the night how much have
you had to drink I probably had about
three drinks what's what's what is three
drinks do you like are we talking what
type of drinks
like right now if you
if you have a test I think I would pass
just not don't test me but I think I
would okay I'm gonna be honest we are
going to do those tests here a little
bit because the Cirque Dans obviously we
have to okay
um how long ago was your last drink
would you say
I drink I would say about 40 minutes 40
minutes ago where you drink anything
while you're in the vehicle or was the
last drink at the bar
okay on a scale of one to ten one being
the least drunk you've ever been 10
being the most drunk you've ever been
where would you say you put yourself at
right now because I've been very drunk
and right now like I see you I see
everyone I know the situation you know
what I mean like I know I'm aware of
everything okay here's I'm gonna close
the door uh if it stops raining we might
do some tests in the roadway otherwise
we might go back to the police station
do it we'll figure out okay we're gonna
do it okay is there yeah we got your
purse your uh phone already that's all
we need out of your car right okay
anytime
all right I'm gonna just run your
information you got a valid license and
all that correct
all right
Stephanie go ahead and step on out here
for me we're gonna do these uh quick
tests it started to ring a little bit
but it pretty much light up as long as
you're okay with that okay all right
come right over here
you can just stand here in front of my
squad car and face me all right just uh
just confirming you said you had
approximately
all right
see my pen right here what I want you to
do is follow the tip of my pen I'm going
to move my pen back and forth several
times you want me to like walk or just
my eyes nope we're just doing your eyes
right now once you follow tip my pen if
your eyes your eyes only but keep your
head still I want you to continue that
test so I tell you to stop okay sir you
understand yes all right touch the tip
of my pin just so you know
nope keep your head still for me oh my
head
okay
all right okay okay
keep their head still for me
it's so far
the best you can just follow up your
eyes
are you able to hold your head still
without your hands okay all right just
lift your eyes okay
he found one
keep looking out to the side there you
go
looking at it to the side
okay
nicely yep okay okay
that's right okay
I'd rather do the one please okay go up
keep your head straight just look up
with your eyes
keep your head tilted down we're gonna
try that again just look up like you're
looking up the sky but keep your head
down
one more time on that okay
okay come right over here for the next
test okay
what I'm going to have you do is stand
about right here face my car we don't
have a line we're going to pretend
there's an invisible line straight from
you to my license plate okay can you see
my license plate fine
all right that's the area we're gonna
shoot for we're gonna walk towards that
okay what I want you to do is put your
left foot down first now put your right
foot in front of your left foot with
your right heel touching your left toe
just as I'm demonstrating go ahead go
and get in that position for me can I
show an example yeah I want you to go
and tie your shoe for me okay
okay what I want exactly as I'm
demonstrating put your left foot down
now put your right foot in front of your
left foot your right heel touching your
left toe stay in that position while
explaining the instructions do not begin
until I tell you to Okay Hand straight
down your side
when I say you're going to take nine
Heel To Toe steps down the line you're
going to turn around take nine heel toe
steps back okay
when I say you're going to take nine
heal the toe steps down this line you're
going to turn around take nine Heel To
Toe steps back on your on your turn I
want you to keep your front foot on the
line then you're going to use your other
foot to turn yourself around with
several small steps okay this is what
it's going to look
this is what it's gonna look like this
position you're in when I say go one two
three on down to nine keep that front
foot on the line use your other foot to
turn yourself around with several small
steps nope stay in that position go back
just the same one two three and on down
to nine okay again I just did three for
demonstration purposes I'm gonna have
you do nine each way during this test
make sure you watch your feet at all
times keep your arms straight down your
side count out loud so I can hear you
once you begin the test do not stop
until you have completed the test okay
yeah do you understand my instructions I
think so all right go ahead and begin
the test okay
yes ma'am
all right if you get a stand right here
in front of me for the next test go and
face me put both your feet together arms
straight down your side this is called a
one leg stance test okay whichever leg
you choose I'm going to have you lift at
approximately six inches off the ground
with your foot parallel to the ground
holding that position what you count out
loud for 30 seconds in a family man or
1001 1002 1003 and so on until you give
it 30 seconds or until I tell you to
stop okay during this test make sure you
watch your race foot at all times keep
your arms straight down your side count
out loud so I can hear you that's what's
gonna look like position you're in when
I say go you're gonna lift your foot up
one thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five and so on to get 30
seconds or until I tell you to stop do
you understand no ma'am just as I
demonstrated okay
just as I demonstrated did you see my
see my demonstration just like this your
foot parallel to the ground
do you understand all right go and begin
the test okay
drop your foot lift it right back up
keep going where you left off
continue the test okay
[Music]
okay
all right we'll stop the test right
there go ahead stand right here by the
front bumper one last s for you okay
just stay right here for me
this is called a PBT test you ever blown
one of these before okay
you know what the legal limit is to
drive in Illinois
okay .08 okay I'm gonna have you do is
take a deep breath a long hard steady
blow into the straw just like you're
blowing up a balloon keep blowing till
you hear the machine click okay all
right yes ma'am take a deep breath long
hard steady blow
a little bit harder for me a little bit
harder keep going keep going okay
you're a Bradley student I graduate in
four weeks 0.264 okay okay all right
okay go in turn around for me and place
your hands down your back you are under
arrest for DUI okay
foreign
okay however you want to word it to
yourself that's fine okay I'm just
telling you there's two people struck by
your vehicle and both both are dead
okay
okay well I'm just telling you the two
people that hit your truck ma'am listen
two people struck your vehicle so I'm
telling you and they're both deceased on
scene I'm just telling you that
information okay we're gonna go in here
we're gonna do the thing I appreciate
you being cooperative so far I'm just
telling I gotta tell you what's going on
you understand yes okay all right come
on out here this way
all right
right over here
just stay right here and grab all this
stuff here
I'm sure there is
um once we get in here we'll tell them
they'll probably take it off for you
okay all right come follow me
right those emergency doors here
oh your whole front windshield was
shattered out so that's understandable
okay
it feels too I'd be crying you know what
I mean I'd be like oh my God
but I know what I did okay
[Music]
I'm gonna spend at least 500.
I'm gonna start off with two Long
Islands
yes
you ever had enough of drinking already
we're talking about Vegas
right have you been there
I swear to God if you're Snapchatting
right now and I'm not good I'm gonna be
mad
oh my God
I'm not gonna answer anyone's Snapchats
you're gonna be like bro I'm at home
okay well you're being too quiet so I'm
gonna start singing Because I hate quiet
you gotta figure out a little paperwork
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yeah
oh hey you never answered me about my
car and then high school tomorrow so how
do I get my car for tomorrow
your car is told
your car is totaled totally total
wrecked
you don't
I don't go to school tomorrow
[Music]
no ma'am you want me to be honest with
you you're going to jail you don't have
a bond you kill two people tonight I
don't think you understand that
you do not have a bond you are not
getting out of jail
your car is property of East Peoria
Police Department because it's a crime
scene it killed two people tonight you
are clueless with that clearly I've
already explained this to you
you're going to jail for reckless
homicide tonight you're going to jail
for aggravated DUI for killing two
people that's what's going on so no
you're not going to school tomorrow
you're not getting your car out of
inbound
did you just hear it I just told you you
said I'm not going tomorrow
you're going to jail right when they're
down here yes did you understand what I
told that you killed two people tonight
yes
good
your own body is going to be completely
careless about killing two people
tonight you could care less
that's sad empathetic and horrible all
the same time can you say that every
time yes ma'am I care okay so can I ask
him so
let's start using my professors
would it be quite frankly I'm a little
more concerned about the two people that
are dead right now
to be fair
all right
uh unless they were in her purse and I
took and I don't think so
okay
yeah
we got I mean we got the DUI kid done
already or just uh because she had some
glass in her foot they brought her back
I had a doctor look at her foot but
we're just waiting for the discharge
paperwork
all right thank you
or something
oh my God all of them
come on dogs
it's okay they're taking me to Vegas my
birthday
[Music]
thank you